commenceront à travailler, nous n'aurons plus besoin de le faire,
ce qui nous libérera des corvées et des durs labeurs.
Quand je parle de ça avec mes amis
à Cambridge et à Silicon Valley, ils disent :
« Génial. Plus de corvées, plus de durs labeurs.
Ça nous donne la possibilité d'imaginer
une société entièrement différente,
une société où les créateurs, découvreurs,
acteurs et innovateurs
se réunissent avec leurs clients et leurs bailleurs de fonds
pour évoquer et envisager divers sujets,
s'inspirer mutuellement et confronter leurs idées. »
Une société qui, dans le fond, ressemble beaucoup à une conférence TED.
Et il y a en ça une grande part de vérité.
Nous voyons une incroyable éclosion prendre forme.
Dans un monde où générer un objet
est tout aussi facile que d'imprimer un document,
les possibilités qui s'offrent à nous sont fascinantes.
Ceux qui étaient naguère des artisans et des amateurs
sont de nos jours des concepteurs et ont à leur actif
des tonnes d'innovations.
Des artistes qui se sentaient limités
peuvent maintenant faire des choses qui ne leur avaient jamais été possibles
auparavant.
Nous sommes donc dans une période florissante.
Et plus j'observe, plus je suis convaincu
que cette citation du physicien Freeman Dyson
n'est pas hyperbolique du tout.
Il s'agit là d'un constat.
Nous vivons au cours d'une période fascinante.
Ce qui soulève une autre grande question :
qu'est-ce qui pourrait bien mal tourner dans cette nouvelle ère des machines ?
Hein ? Persévère, prospère, puis rentre à la maison.
Nous allons faire face à deux séries de défis particulièrement épineux
à mesure que nous nous enfonçons dans le futur que nous sommes en train de créer.
Les premiers sont d'ordre économique et joliment résumés
par un échange apocryphe
entre Henry Ford II et Walter Reuther,
qui était à la tête du syndicat des ouvriers de l'automobile.
Alors qu'ils faisaient la tournée des nouvelles usines modernes
Ford, se tourna vers Reuther et lui dit d'un air jovial :
« Hé Walter, comment tu vas t'y prendre pour faire payer
les cotisations syndicales à ces robots ? »
Et Reuther réplique : « Hé Henry,
comment tu vas t'y prendre pour leur faire acheter des voitures ? »
Le problème de Reuther dans cette anecdote
est qu'il est difficile de proposer sa force de travail
dans une économie pleine de machines,
et c'est clairement se que disent les statistiques.
Si on regarde les dernières décennies,
le retour sur capital, -- c'est-à-dire les profits des entreprises,
a augmenté. Et on voit qu'il est maintenant
à son plus haut niveau jamais atteint.
Si on regarde le retour sur travail, c'est à dire
le total des salaires dans l'économie,
on voit qu'il se trouve à son niveau le plus bas
et qu'il continue à dégringoler à vive allure.
C'est clairement une mauvaise nouvelle pour Reuther.
On pourrait croire que c'est une bonne nouvelle pour Ford,
mais en fait non. Si on veut vendre
de grandes quantités de marchandises relativement chères,
ce qu'il faut c'est une classe moyenne large, stable et prospère.
Nous avons connu cela en Amérique
pendant presque toute la période d'après-guerre.
Mais la classe moyenne fait aujourd'hui face à une grande menace.
Nous avons tous la tête pleine de ces statistiques,
mais je vais en reprendre juste une :
le revenu médian en Amérique a baissé
sur les 15 dernières années,
et nous courrons le risque de tomber dans
un cercle vicieux où l'inégalité et la polarisation
continuent à s'accroître avec le temps.
Les phénomènes de société qui accompagnent
ce genre d'inégalités méritent notre attention.
Il s'agit d'une série de changements de société
qui ne me préoccupent pas tant que ça
et que des images comme celle-ci rendent bien.
Ce n'est pas le genre de problèmes de société
qui me préoccupe.
Les dystopies sur ce qui se passera
quand nos machines deviendront conscientes et décideront
de se soulever et de nous attaquer ne manquent pas.
Je commencerai à me faire du souci là-dessus
le jour où mon ordinateur reconnaîtra mon imprimante.
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Il ne s'agit donc pas des défis dont nous devons nous soucier.
Pour vous aborder les défis de société
auxquels nous serons confrontés dans la nouvelle ère des machines,
je vais vous raconter une histoire sur deux travailleurs américains typiques.
Pour en faire de vrais stéréotypes,
disons qu'ils sont tous les deux blancs.
Le premier a un diplôme universitaire,
il est du type créatif, du genre manager,
ingénieur, docteur, avocat... ce genre-là.
On va l'appeler Ted.
Il représente le haut de la classe moyenne américaine.
L'autre n'a pas de diplôme universitaire,
il est ouvrier, employé de bureau,
a un emploi dans un secteur tertiaire de bas-niveau ou secondaire.
On va appeler ce gars-là Bill.
Si vous remontez 50 ans en arrière,
Bill et Ted menaient des vies remarquablement semblables.
Par exemple, en 1960, ils avaient tous les deux toutes les chances
d'avoir un emploi à plein temps, d'au moins 40 heures par semaine.
Mais comme l'a démontré, documents à l'appui, le sociologue Charles Murray,
à mesure que nous avons automatisé l'économie,
et 1960 n'est que le point de départ de l'utilisation des ordinateurs par les entreprises,
à mesure que nous avons commencé à injecter progressivement de la technologie,
des automates et des outils numériques dans l'économie,
le sort de Bill et celui de Ted ont beaucoup divergé.
Sur toute cette échelle de temps, Ted a gardé
un emploi à plein temps. Mais pas Bill.
Dans de nombreux cas, Bill a entièrement disparu de l'économie,
alors que Ted presque jamais.
Avec le temps, le couple de Ted a bien tenu.
Pas celui de Bill.
Les enfants de Ted ont grandi dans un foyer à deux parents,
alors que ceux de Bill, tout au contraire, à mesure qu'on avance dans le temps.
D'autres formes d'exclusion sociale de Bill ?
Son abstention aux élections présidentielles a augmenté,
et il a commencé à aller en prison bien plus souvent.
Je ne peux pas raconter une histoire heureuse sur ces tendances sociales
de même qu'elles ne montrent aucun signe d'inversion.
Elles restent vraies quel que soit le groupe ethnique
ou démographique observé,
et elles prennent une telle ampleur
qu'elles risquent même d'effacer
les incroyables progrès réalisés grâce au mouvement des droits civiques.
Ce que mes amis à Silicon Valley et à Cambridge
refusent de voir c'est qu'ils sont Ted.
Ils vivent une vie pleine, épatante, productive,
avec tous les avantages qui vont avec,
alors que Bill lui mène une vie bien différente.
Tous deux démontrent que Voltaire ne s'était pas trompé
lorsqu'il parlait des bénéfices du travail
et du fait qu'il nous éloigne non pas d'un mais de trois grands maux.
[« Le travail éloigne de nous trois grands maux : l'ennui, le vice et le besoin. »]
Ces défis, qu'est-ce qu'on en fait ?
Le scénario économique est étonnamment clair là-dessus,
étonnamment direct, et encore plus catégorique à court terme.
Les robots ne vont pas nous voler tous nos emplois dans les deux ans à venir,
donc la théorie économique classique suffira à :
encourager l'entrepreneuriat,
doubler la mise sur les infrastructures
et s'assurer que notre système éducatif
produise des individus avec les compétences appropriées.
Mais sur le long terme, si on se dirige vers une économie
à haute teneur en technologie et faible teneur en force de travail,
comme c'est le cas, alors il nous faut envisager
des interventions plus radicales,
par exemple, quelque chose comme un revenu minimum garanti.
Certains dans cette pièce pourraient se sentir mal à l'aise en entendant ça,
parce que cette idée est associée à l'extrême gauche
et à des programmes de redistribution des richesses plutôt radicaux.
Je me suis penché sur cette notion
et ça pourrait calmer certains esprits de savoir
que l'idée d'un revenu net minimum garanti
a été défendue par ces socialistes enragés que sont
Friedrich Hayek, Richard Nixon et Milton Friedman.
Et si vous en venez à vous faire du souci
en pensant qu'un tel revenu garanti
pourrait nous enlever l'envie de réussir
et nous rendre fainéants,
vous serez peut-être curieux d'entendre que la mobilité sociale,
une des choses qui fait notre fierté aux Etats-Unis,
est aujourd'hui inférieure à ce qu'elle est dans les pays d'Europe du Nord
qui ont ces minima sociaux si généreux.
Le scénario économique est bien simple et direct.
Celui qui traite de la société pose bien plus de questions.
Je ne sais pas quel scénario peut donner à Bill
l'opportunité de trouver un emploi et de le conserver toute sa vie.
Ce que je sais c'est que l'éducation joue un grand rôle.
J'en ai fait l'expérience moi-même.
J'ai été un enfant Montessori pendant les premières années de ma scolarité,
et ce que cette éducation m'a appris
c'est que le monde est un lieu intéressant
et que mon rôle est de l'explorer.
L'école s'arrêtait à la troisième année,
alors je suis entré dans le système éducatif public
et j'ai eu l'impression d'être envoyé au goulag.
Avec le recul, je sais que le but
était de me préparer à une vie d'employé de bureau ou d'ouvrier,
mais à l'époque j'avais l'impression que le but
était de me noyer d'ennui jusqu'à ce que je me fonde dans le moule.
Nous devons faire mieux que ça.
Nous ne pouvons pas continuer à produire des Bill.
Nous voyons les prémisses d'une amélioration.
Nous voyons l'impact profond que la technologie a sur l'éducation
et sur le recrutement du personnel, du plus bas
au plus haut niveau d'instruction.
Nous entendons les voix de milieux d'affaires à succès nous dire
que nous devons repenser certaines des choses qui nous tiennent le plus à cœur.
Et ce à quoi l'on assiste, est le déploiement d’efforts soutenus et sérieux,
afin de trouver, grâce aux données disponibles,
le moyen d'intervenir auprès de certaines de nos populations les plus sensibles.
Les signes encourageants sont donc là.
Je ne veux pas avoir l'air de dire, ne serait-ce qu'un instant,
que ce que nous avons suffira.
Nous sommes confrontés à des défis de taille.
Pour donner un seul exemple, il y a environ 5 millions d'Américains.
qui sont au chômage depuis au moins six mois.
Nous n'arriverons pas à régler leurs problèmes
en les renvoyant au Montessori.
Et ma plus grosse préoccupation, est que nous créions un monde
regorgeant de technologies reluisantes,
mais incorporées dans une société vétuste,
soutenue par une économie qui génère de l'inégalité
au lieu de générer des opportunités.
Mais en réalité je ne crois pas que nous allons faire ça.
Je crois que nous allons faire bien mieux
pour une raison très simple :
ces choses commencent à se savoir.
Les réalités de cette nouvelle ère des machines
et les changement économiques commencent à mieux être compris.
Si on voulait accélérer le processus, on pourrait par exemple
opposer nos meilleurs économistes et dirigeants
à Watson au « Jeopardy ».
On pourrait envoyer le Parlement en voyage à bord d'une voiture automate.
Si on faisait assez de choses comme ça,
on parviendrait à ancrer dans l'esprit des gens que les choses vont changer.
Et dés lors, tout est possible,
car je ne crois pas un instant
que nous ayons oublié comment surmonter des défis de taille,
ou que nous soyons devenus trop apathiques ou insensibles pour nous y mettre.
J'ai commencé ma présentation par des citations de gens de lettres
que séparent un océan et un siècle.
Je finirai, si vous le permettez, par les mots
d'hommes politiques tout aussi distants.
Winston Churchill est venu au MIT, mon foyer, en 1949
et a dit : « Si vous devons amener les masses
du peuple de chaque terre à la table de l'abondance,
ce ne sera que par l'amélioration incessante
de tous nos moyens techniques de production. »
Abraham Lincoln s'était rendu compte qu'il y avait un autre ingrédient.
Il a dit : « J'ai une grande confiance dans le peuple.
Si la vérité lui est donnée, on peut lui faire confiance
pour surmonter n'importe quelle crise nationale.
L'essentiel est de lui présenter les faits tels qu'ils sont. »
La note optimiste, essentiel sur laquelle je vous quitterai,
est que les faits concernant l'ère des machines apparaissent de plus en plus tels qu'ils sont
et j'ai toute confiance de croire que nous les utiliserons
pour nous guider à bon port dans l'économie
d'exigence et d'abondance que nous sommes en train de créer.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)